a lack of confidence is often put down
to something we call shyness
but beneath shyness there may lie
something more surprising pernicious and
poignant
we suffer from a suspicion of ourselves
that gives us a sense that other people
will always have good reasons to dislike
us
to think ill of us to question our
motives and to mock us
we then become scared of the world speak
in a small voice don't dare to show our
face at gatherings and are frightened of
social occasions because we fear that we
are ideal targets for ridicule and
disdain our shy manner is the preemptive
stance we adopt in the face of the blows
we feel that other people want to land
on us
our shyness is rooted in a sense of
unworthiness
as shy people when we find ourselves in
a foreign city in which we know no one
we can be thrown into a panic at the
prospect of having to enter a busy
restaurant and order a meal on our own
dogged by a feeling that no one
especially wants to know us that we are
outside the charmed circle of the
popular and the desirable we are sure
that our leprous condition will be
noticed by others and that we will be
the target of sneering and viciousness
we unknowingly impute to strangers the
nasty comments that we are experts at
making to ourselves
our self-image returns to haunt us in
the assumed views of others
we imagine that groups of friends will
take mean delight in our solitary state
and read into it appalling conclusions
about our nature
they will see right through our veneer
of competence and adulthood and detect
the deformed and unfinished creature we
have felt like since the start
they will know how desperate we have
been to win friends and how pitiful and
isolated we are even the waiter will
fight to restrain their desire to giggle
at our expense in the kitchen
a comparable fear haunts us at the idea
of going into a clothes shop the sales
assistant will surely immediately sense
how unfit we are to lay claim to the
stylishness on offer they may suspect we
lack the money they will be appalled by
our physique we lack the right to pamper
our own bodies
it can be as much of a hurdle to attend
a party here too our fundamental
imagined awfulness is perpetually at
risk of being noticed and exploited by
others
as we try to join a group of people
chatting animatedly
we dread that they will swiftly realize
how unfunny we are how craven our nature
is and how peculiar and damned we are at
our core
the novelist franz kafka who hated
himself with rare energy
famously imagined himself into the role
of a cockroach
this move of the imagination will feel
familiar to anyone sick with self
disdain
we the self-hating ones
spontaneously identify with all the
stranger less photogenic animals
rhinoceroses blobfish
spiders warthogs elephant seals
we skulk in corners we run away from our
shadow we live in fear of being swatted
away and killed
it is no surprise if against such an
internal background we end up shy
the solution is not to urge us blithely
to be more confident
it is to help us to take stock of our
feelings about ourselves that we have
ascribed to an audience that is in
reality far more innocent and
unconcerned than we ever imagine
we need to trace our self-hatred back to
its origins repatriate and localize it
and drain it of its power to infect our
views of those we encounter
everyone else isn't cheering or bored or
convinced of our revoltingness
these are our certainties not theirs
we don't have to whisper in a
circumspect manner and enter each new
conversation restaurant or shop with a
sheepish air of apology
we can cast aside our introverted
circumspection once we realize the
distortions of our self-perception
and can come to believe in a world that
has far better things to do than to
despise us
how to survive the modern world explores
why some key features of modern life
including capitalism and the rise of
individualism can have harmful effects
on our psychological health from there
it provides solutions
ways of rethinking and surviving
modernity